porque los nicaragüenses acuden a las
urnas para las elecciones presidenciales
del próximo 7 de noviembre en las que el
mandatario daniel ortega busca ser
reelegido por cuarta vez por cuarta vez
consecutiva tras una campaña marcada por
una ola de arrestos contra los
principales precandidatos opositores
ante todo esto el gobierno sandinista es
acusado de liderar y crear una campaña
virtual a través de cuentas falsas en
facebook para así favorecer a la
candidatura de ortega y atacar a los
opositores son 4.3 millones de
nicaragüenses que están habilitados para
votar en este proceso electoral
calificado por eeuu como una farsa y al
que no asistan los observadores
internacionales que habitualmente
acompañan los procesos en américa
latina' para ello quiero saludar
entonces en este momento a nuestra
primera invitada ella es soraya
rodríguez eurodiputada de europa en la
delegación de ciudadanos de europa
además trabaja en igualdad y desarrollo
de derechos humanos entre otras cosas
que hace es ahora ya soraya gracias por
su tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa en france24 le preguntó
por las garantías democráticas para esta
elección y realmente hay
bueno garantías democráticas ninguna
está claro que estamos ante
una farsa del proceso electoral los
todos los candidatos todos los que han
osado presentarse en estas elecciones
están encarcelados y la prensa libre ha
sido perseguida tenemos
1700 políticos en nicaragua y por lo
tanto desde la unión europea y desde el
parlamento europeo nos vamos a plantear
un món fraude electoral como el que ha
preparado el régimen de ortega y murillo
para este próximo domingo como catalogan
ustedes como bloque como unión europea
estas elecciones
lo acabo de decir lo calificamos como un
fraude electoral el 78% de los
nicaragüenses se consideran que estar en
estas elecciones son ilegítimas y más
del 65% desde luego no votaría si
tuvieran a un régimen a un candidato oa
una opción política distinta que no
fuera la opción política de ortega y
murillo ahora de unas elecciones con
kate o que tengan los mínimos requisitos
democráticos cuando no hay una
posibilidad de concurrencia
en igualdad de condiciones del resto de
fuerzas políticas pero es que quiero
señalar que hemos asistido en los
últimos meses a una verdadera cacería de
aquellas personas que han optado por
decir que querían presentarse y
concurrir a estas elecciones todos ellos
están en prisión ha habido también una
persecución clara a la prensa a la
libertad de prensa a medios no afines al
régimen en nicaragua y hemos observado
como los periodistas o titulares de
estos medios están encarcelados o han
tenido que huir del país presos
políticos en las cárceles en las que
llevamos reclamando su puesta en
libertad y más de 328 personas
asesinadas desde las protestas de 2018
en las que no ha habido justicia para
ellos por lo tanto no hay ningún
requisito para que podemos podamos
hablar de elecciones democráticas
y cualquier connivencia con este fraude
no sería más que legitimar un proceso
electoral que no es tal es realmente un
fraude electoral democrático soraya
también como lo estábamos adelantando en
nuestro panorama informativo aquí en
directo américa ya la corte
interamericana derechos humanos ordenó
que el gobierno nicaragüense libere a la
aspirante presidencial cristiana
chamorro ya 13 personas más como lo
estabas diciendo que casi todos los que
se apuntaron digamos a hacer candidatos
presidenciales están lamentablemente
detenidos le pregunto entonces la
situación en materia de los derechos
humanos en nicaragua y sobre todo con
estas personas que están detenidas que
muchos también familiares denunciaban
que no habían podido tener acceso a
estas personas que estaban detenidas ni
sus abogados y qué pasa en mi cargo con
los derechos humanos y además ustedes
como unión europea' que pudieran hacer
para ayudar a que esta situación mejore
pues mire efectivamente la situación de
los derechos humanos en nicaragua es la
es una situación de enorme espiral de
represión y creo sinceramente que hay
que calificar al régimen de ortega y
murillo como lo que hoy realmente es y
es una dictadura desde el parlamento
europeo hemos impulsado distintas
resoluciones desde luego pidiendo con el
resto de la comunidad internacional la
inmediata liberación de todos los presos
políticos yo he tenido también
oportunidad de reunirme durante estos
últimos meses con familiares con las
asociaciones de familiares de presos
políticos en nicaragua y créanme que en
las condiciones a las que están
sometidos son terribles teniendo en
cuenta además en un contexto de epidemia
sanitaria como el kobe en el que desde
luego la gestión por parte del cob y por
parte del régimen ortega ha sido
verdaderamente brutal para toda la
población
en este sentido desde la unión europea
hemos impulsado sanciones al régimen y a
altos cargos del régimen de ortega
murillo en el marco de nuestra nueva ley
de sanciones contra la vulneración de
derechos humanos
y además hemos ido más allá y en el
último pleno yo personalmente he pedido
que ampliaremos todas estas sanciones a
la familia ortega y murillo que
realmente se ha convertido en una
sociedad anónima familiar
que tiene hipotecado todo el país
hipotecado el país e hipotecado los
derechos y libertades de todos los
nicaragüenses sí creo que tenemos que
seguir presionando denunciar de forma
clara esta situación llamar a este
régimen de ortega y murillo por su
nombre una dictadura una de las peores
dictaduras que hay ahora en américa
latina y que el régimen
tenga muy claro un mensaje no cabe otra
salida que una solución una transición
democrática en aragua una solución
dialogada pero desde luego no va a haber
la menor connivencia con este régimen
mientras los derechos y libertades de
los nicaragüenses estén siendo
pisoteadas por lo tanto libertad
inmediata de los presos políticos
apertura de un canal de diálogo en el
hambre de la comunidad internacional
para restaurar a través de un diálogo y
de transición democrática contando con
todas las fuerzas políticas
nicaragüenses la democracia en este país